um  i mean i knew it i wasn't trying to  think about it and it was more so the  way the game was going it was  it was kind of uh  everything i just talked about but it  was it was cool to  you know reach that milestone it's  pretty  awesome accomplishment in terms of  you know something that hadn't been done  in nba in history so  it's kind of  a weird thought to think for the rest of  my career for the most part i'm pretty  sure every three i make will be a new  record so  i'm just gonna enjoy it and  i don't know what's the next milestone  like three three three three or like  you gotta start coming up with stuff  you know  so see y'all see y'all next year  [Applause]